CSU-Parteitag hier spricht man sich klar
gegen Cannabis aus hier sagt man Nein zu
Rauschmitteln Bayern ist nicht das Land
der Käfer nein
[Musik]
Respekt so fürs erste Mal muss man aber
dazu sagen bei uns zu Hause würde so
zwei Zwergerl halbe gar nicht ausschenkt
werden das haben ja nur 03 was halten
Sie denn von dem neuen eckdatenpapier
von Herrn Lauterbach was die Cannabis
Legalisierung angeht ja ich bin der
Bezirk und kann das ja explizit auch
darüber sprechen dass es also die
falscheste Entscheidung ist die in der
Politik seit langem gehört habe
und die Ilse Aigner wird man das auch
bestätigen denn Cannabis frei ist etwas
das wir noch mehr Suchtkranke haben er
lügt sich das sowas in die Tasche und
hat es selber noch gar nicht gespannt so
schauts aus sehen sie haben sie halt
schon getrunken schon einiges intos ja
ja ja
wofür sind sie eher für bauen oder für
brauen
umzubauen war die Lösung bauen
umzubrauen genau also joints bauen
bauen gesagt das war aber auf joints
bezogen also sind sie eher für joints
als vier Bier
eindeutig für Spiel aber sie haben es
anders gesagt
ich habe was dabei ich habe was dabei
okay gut für Sie
warum denn nicht nein wir machen das ja
hinter der Kamera nein es ist sehr zum
Ausprobieren das ist ein No-Go
[Musik]
sind ja beim Thema Cannabis sind sie ja
im Team Vorsicht wann werden sie diesmal
das Team wechseln nein da bin ich im
Team verboten
ich weiß dass ihr bei euch in der
Redaktion das braucht um etwas lockerer
zu werden aber nee aber dafür wird hier
ganz gut gesoffen ne also hier beim
Parteitag ja von mir nicht
Weg soziale Armut drauf ist weg
Bestechungsgelder aber was ist was denn
hier los wer sitzt denn hier ja mal ganz
ehrlich das war ganz kurz hier
hochhalten darf
Erdinger Alkoholfrei wer ist denn der
Herr Ebersberg das ist das für ein Typ
tut mir leid mir ist alles mögliche
Oberbayern
also von denen Distanz
Zitrone das ist sowas gibt Bayern lebt
von den
Metzgern und auch von dem Brauern und
die Metzger das sind die die das
Christel mitmachen von den versöhne
immer geredet hat wie stehen sie denn so
zur Cannabis Legalisierung
ich persönlich komme aber darüber
nachdenken weil hier mit der ich sag mal
bei der CSU ist man ja schon ziemlich
dagegen habe ich so den Eindruck ne naja
da gibt es verschiedene Meinungen
ehrlich in der CSU gibt es verschiedene
Meinungen werden noch die Meinung dass
man über Legalisierung nachdenken könnte
Einstieg immer mehr mehr und dann ist
die Abhängigkeit extrem größer Bayer
Cannabis als einstiegsdrucker
wissenschaftlich widerlegt ist
der Wissenschaft glaube ich nicht so
einfach kann man sich natürlich auch
machen und wenn Sie jetzt die Wahl
hätten zwischen einem Joint und einem
norddeutschen Pilz da würde ich
natürlich klicken wenn Sie jetzt die
Wahl hätten zwischen einem Joint und
einem norddeutschen veganen Pils
ja so sehr hassen sie Cannabis ja
endlich Schnaps und weiter
geht's deutlich sein
[Applaus]
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekanntgeben
es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf Youtube
boah also ich würde mich ranhalten